four times four times
this cutie guy
look what he's having for breakfast
cookies
no i'm just kidding he actually did such
a good job today i gave him cereal
it's stuck at the top are you kidding me
now he uh he crushed his breakfast and
because of that he earned himself a
snack because we never want to ruin his
breakfast so it's like you could have a
snack if you finish breakfast and how
fast did you eat the cereal today
so fast and four how many cookies you
want
four of them
that might be all of them that's awesome
do you want four and a half because
there's a half in there too
one two and a little plate three
four
you're gonna say four that's five
there's four that's too much huh there
you go watch out don't don't do it
sounds ridiculous i just came back from
l.a so i was like kind of groggy a
little bit because i came in at like
midnight
and i went outside to take the trash in
because i was like oh i've got to take
out the trash and it's coming out all
groggy and what's cute is i met our new
neighbors just moved that just moved in
and the first thing they said was cool
robe and i was like huh
i was like oh yeah that's dope i always
forget that i'm adult sometimes because
i just like random things and this is my
cool ninja turtle road with my ninja
turtle back
and so i guess probably
the new neighbors got a kick out of that
they're a little bit older than me
because their kids are uh
i think like 16 and 21
so they're probably like ah this guy
is still the case down earth which is
cool and i'm glad that they liked my
robe which means there's a kid in them
so i can't wait to get to know them
we just shot our very first episode of
get close
and i got everything
up to operation as close as possible but
you know when you have something new
there's always things you have to fine
tune and so i bought a bunch of things
from amazon so that we can fix
everything
one of them being a timer i bought this
cool timer that we had at jk and i think
it was misadvertised on amazon because
it said it was a timer not just the led
clock but when i plugged it in the only
function it had
was a clock and we need a timer to know
how long we're going to be talk for 20
minutes did we talk for an hour and a
half or whatever
and so i took the crossfit timer from
inside
the garage here
i thought that would work because it
counts up but the problem is after 20
minutes it just shut off i don't know
what happened
so i bought another one from amazon
and this one does indeed have the uh
count up
option
and then i look and it's battery
operated i'm like dude
this is gonna make workflow a pain in
the butt because now every time i'm
shooting i have to check batteries
and it can go out in the middle of shoot
which is a nightmare and i wanted
something that plugged in so i don't
know maybe it's my fault for not
choosing anything that's name brand i
just keep buying amazon brand products
or
these random like chinese or chinese
brands on amazon i don't know
and the reason why anthony
was our first
uh
guest
not just because he's my brother and
close friend
but when we're used to shoot bailcast at
the old jk office
anthony's episode for some reason was
the only one that didn't make it i don't
know if it was like the file got
corrupted or the sound didn't work or
something and it was such a good
heartfelt episode
that i felt sad that it didn't make it
so he had to be
the first one and the podcast we shot
with them was amazing i loved it which
is why i'm like you know what
we do have a pretty sick setup now i
have like audio set up in there i have
all the cords i have everything labeled
as you can see like even the headphones
are labeled like right here
guest h meaning guest headphones
these are the mics so i know everything
like if it's working or not and exactly
how to troubleshoot but i'm like i'm not
gonna leave anything up to chance
i should have done this before
but i got a quick little mic that i can
put on
one of these cameras right here
so that
if the audio goes out we have backup
audio it's not going to sound as good of
course but at least we have backup
audio so these are just little things
i'm picking up as i'm shooting
one of the other things is the
headphones cord
is kind of short
so i bought some more headphone cord so
that way
when we're filming you don't just see a
line that's all stretched out on top
like that
and i think
that's about it oh and also
because we have so many angles now like
we have one
two three
and four
each podcast has way more files which
means
it's going to look sick and you know you
have a lot of angles you could punch in
and do so much and looks visually uh
very stimulating i'll really get sucked
into the conversation but on the
workflow end
you can lose a lot more footage so i'm
getting a backup hard drive so that way
i have duplicates of every single
podcast because that's something that we
didn't have before because it's so easy
to manage files but now that we have so
many files and not to mention it takes a
lot for the guests to come here like for
example today we're going to be filming
with tim
it took a lot for me to get here you
know so i don't want half i don't have
anything to get deleted or not have a
backup and then i'm like oh shoot i
don't know when the next time i can
schedule tim and so these are just a few
things that i'm picking up uh to
hopefully make the podcast that much
smoother
vegas we were supposed to go home today
but geo's like please come in
bench press what do you call her
like i want a protein girl
iron queen whatever
iron queen that's pretty dull
that's sick oh how are you liking our
baby i love her
you're so chill you're not gonna go back
okay we'll take no no no oh you don't
want that dude
that guy will ruin your life dude you
don't want him
i know she's like scarves oh god she
just started crawling i'm already
exhausted really oh how cute
that's awesome oh man she keeps like
bouncing out like she wants to get out
there oh yeah but if you play some music
she starts like
whoa whoa
youtube parents dude can't believe it
man look at us vlogging each other look
at this old ass youtubers oh my god
it's crazy i know right grown
kids
wow red pink
theo's ninja turtle socks mister
oh my god
oh yeah i didn't finish what are you
guys gonna do with it so we're probably
gonna do something similar to our old
house where there's like a pool and like
some grass play area
oh yeah that's the one cool part of this
vegas you might like there's no
mosquitoes taquitos love me i know but
there's no mosquitoes out here that's
amazing so you can kick it out here
without getting bit
without getting malaria malaria prone
oh yeah
yeah there's a decent amount of space
one thing i actually do want to get you
know um
you know those air streams like the old
school silver rv looking things looks
like a round like silver twinkie oh yeah
yeah yeah i actually want to put one
over there oh that's cool so it'll be
like an extra kick it spot you know yeah
it's cool
look at you it's almost like a like a
little rustic museum yeah dude
i'm kind of creative sometimes dude yeah
i like it yeah dude thank you bro
just finished our podcast
and we ordered some barbecue for lunch i
love this oh my goodness i love this
place they're so good
they're called the big bees we got
ribs
we got brisket oh my lord
oh yeah
he's doing
the you know that trend was like three
years ago
hey don't hit the ceiling dude
i literally heard you hit the ceiling
i know you i know you're doing a bottle
flip but don't hit the ceiling
yeah do a small one look a small one
like that
too big too big have you guys oh you
guys probably don't watch this
uh
this guy watched dude perfect there you
go
and then i was like oh that's a
wholesome thing from the watch on
youtube you know
and then now he wants to throw
everything in the air
yeah yeah so he's like launching balls
off the walls and all that and i'm like
i didn't know he's going to be corrupted
like that
double
oh he almost did it
larry says like taika are you gonna get
one next they paid me a visit
and he goes no i'm too little
that's not very nice
and then she goes oh how old are you
four and he's like four she goes okay
how old do you need to be to get a
tattoo
don't do that so much yeah that's fine
but don't play with your friends yeah
don't play with your food mister
dude veda is just watching with your
food veda
with the big